welcome back to new rockstars my name is
mt and this is a breakdown of the
post-credits scene of the season finale
of marvel's what if because after the
season finale of what if gave us the
gift that is the guardians of the
multiverse through one of the coolest
battles in mcu history the post-credit
team gave us marvel nerdy nerd nerds the
greatest gift of all wholesome content
by teasing captain carter's potential
reunion with the corpse of steve rogers
i mean hey the boy was skin and bones
before anyway so who cares if his skin
is a little less
moisturized and alive i mean it worked
for vision and om nom nom dom maximoff
but let us break the scene down shall we
my nerd babies because if you look
closely marvel studios has very much
planted the seeds for captain carter to
face off against a hydra steve rogers in
season two and it might just be a mashup
of the hydropalooza of both cap two and
the mechanized mayhem of iron man 2.
it's going to be like a mash-up episode
but anyways to quickly recap the what-if
finale post-credits scene after captain
carter's bff gnat flash fried zaptrock
the sleeper on the deck of the lumerian
star from captain america 2 natasha
brings peggy to a huge ass metal
containment unit that apparently
contains the hydra stomper from captain
carter's debut episode a retro iron man
suit created by howard stark to be
piloted by all 95 pounds of patriotic
bravery that is won stephen grant rogers
who is heavily implied to be inside the
suit judging by both the black widow's
face when she says and there's someone
inside and the light piano rendition of
the captain america theme playing in the
background and when we get our short
look into the hydra stomp or containment
unit we can notice heartbeat monitors on
the sides suggesting that some or all of
this technology is being used to keep
tabs on and sustain the life of steve
rogers inside of the hydrostomper super
advanced versions of computers built in
the 1970s but that can't be true to
build a super smart computer with 1970s
technology you would have to be some
type of super smart computer man living
in 1970 oh my god i know why steve is in
the hydro stomper steve rogers is
peggy's winner soldier because think
about it if you look at the post credit
stomper you can notice that its design
is a lot different than it used to be
this is essentially a new and upgraded
hydra stomper with a new design that
sports updated shielding a more menacing
mask hints of red on the shoulders and
on the back as well as a red 88 on the
suit's left leg and also the design of
the computers in this containment unit
looked extremely similar to that of
zola's super sick and secret retro
gaming setup at camp lehigh in cap 2.
and also the actual containment unit on
the outside looks a lot like one of the
doors and like the whole infrastructure
of the soviet hydra bunker from captain
america civil war
wait out a man with a metal weapon with
a hint of red being kept in stasis by
retro futuristic microsoft zola
technology hmm sounds a lot like bucky
and his red star winter soldier arm to
me i feel like zola literally had to be
involved with steve's preservation in
the hydra stomper winter soldier stop
because i have a feeling that zola in
this what-if universe was eventually
pardoned by operation paperclip and
eventually went to work for the soviet
union like the main universe zola did i
mean he did cooperate with captain
carter after all i will tell you nothing
well you know after being threatened
with a hard british pegging anyway he
told me everything
it's the cooperation that counts however
instead of working with the soviet union
to turn bucky into the winter soldier
like we did in the movies zolo worked
with the soviet union to mind wipe steve
rogers and turn him into
pause for effect
the winter dynamo because i strongly
believe that something happened to
skinny steve during the events of world
war ii after you know the events of the
what if episode 1 that caused him and
the suit to have been captured by the
soviet union and experimented by zola
and the reason why steve is on the
lumerian star in the first place is
because the lumerian star was a hydra
controlled ship dedicated for launching
satellites for zola's 1984 ass project
insight and thanks to this video sponsor
pedal for featuring the pedal 2 credit
card pedal is a company that wants to
help you succeed financially and that's
why the pedal 2 card is designed to help
you build credit when you apply for
pedal 2 your banking history may be used
to instantly create a cash score a
measure of your credit worthiness based
on income spending and savings it could
help you qualify even if you've never
had a credit score before the pedal 2
visa card has no annual fee and you'll
get one percent cash back right away on
eligible purchases and up to 1.5 percent
cashback when you make 12 on-time
monthly payments their app makes it easy
to track your spending make on-time
payments and manage subscription
spending the pedal 2 credit limit ranges
from 500 to 10 000
based on credit worthiness which can
help keep your credit utilization low a
key component to building credit see if
you're pre-approved without impacting
your credit score and it takes minutes
to apply online and pedal is partnered
with web bank member fdic which issues
the card and as of today the pedal 2
variable aprs range from 12.99
to 26.99 so start building your credit
history go to the link in the
description box below pedal card dot com
slash new rockstar today to find out
more that's pedal with a t pedal p e t a
l
card.com
new rockstars you have to remember that
the only reason why batrock and the
neverwin pirates are doing shenanigans
on that ship in cap two was because
samuel l jackson sent them there as a
distraction because he felt that there
was something fishy going on with shield
and so he said black widow to steal that
shield intel on the low behind cap's
back and i think that it's during this
mission that what if black widow
discovers that the lumerian star was
also where hydra was keeping their
winter dynamo in stasis and off the
books between missions highly likely
with a copy of zola within the container
or the very suit itself mind wiping
steve rogers into submission and it
makes sense too considering that zola
would be limited by the technology of
his time to operate the suit himself
like he does in the wooded finale so he
literally needs steve to operate this
suit because he knows the suit the best
skinny steven what if episode 1 played a
very similar role that bucky did in
captain america one because skinny steve
was the one who had that
life-threatening accident on a train
much like bucky did and he was also
rescued from hydra captivity by captain
carter like bucky was by captain america
so it stands to reason that somehow
during the course of the war he and the
hydro stomper got captured by the soviet
union and turned into their secret
weapon just like bucky was but hey what
about that number 88 on the stomper's
leg well i think a better question is
how the hell did they get this stomper
up and running again that's easy anton
vanko howard stark's old arc reactor
research buddy you know before he tried
to sell howard's secrets on the black
market and got his ass deported back to
the soviet union where he was sentenced
to exile in siberia until the year
1987 and i believe this is when the
soviet union and hydra probably called
on ivan to combine his arc reactor
knowledge with zola's immense tesseract
knowledge to successfully recreate a
miniature arc reactor super early by the
year 1988 hence the 88 on the stomper's
leg with his son ivan eventually picking
up anton's work with hydra after anton's
death in 2009. so this all being said
with project inside seemingly on the
rise i think that season two of what if
is going to start us off with peggy
having to face off against the
mind-controlled love of her life in a
giant iron man suit but this time he has
a russian accent eventually leading us
to the revelation that ivan vanko has
been working in tandem with robozola and
hydra to launch project insight not with
helicarriers this time no but with
pilotless hydra stomper drones mashing
up what whiplash did in iron man 2 with
zola's evil plan and algorithm in falcon
america falcon punch show me a moves
with ivan eventually of course taking
the stomper armor away from either a
reformed or killed hydra mind wipe steve
rogers giving it a fresh coat of red
paint and turning himself into the mcu's
crimson dynamo a title that belonged to
ivan's father anton in the comics and
was teased in black widow earlier this
year the only thing you care about are
your stupid glory days is the crimson
dynamo and no one wants to hear about it
but that is it for this breakdown of the
what if post credit scene like do you
agree with me do you think that we could
see skinny hydra steve try to stomp his
buff british waifu in season 2 let us
know your predictions below my nerd
babies but anyways thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me at mastertainment on twitter
if you want to see me tweet some weird
[ __ ] but most importantly following us
on new rockstars twitter and on youtube
and when you do on youtube make sure you
hit that notification bell and also do
not forget to hit up
newrockstarsmerch.com so you can get
cool shirts like our new venom inspired
shirts and our what-if shirts that are
going to be out of stock very soon so
please head on over to
rockstarsmerch.com to get yourself some
cool nerd [ __ ] i have been mt and i will
see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you